うえっ
ブーバー here にょ
に入りました皆さん一家がお過ごしでしょうか今回はが落ちラテというかで動画の
タイトルを見たらとかわかると思うんですけども実はですねちょっと大切なお話があり
まして僕の生活に関するお話でございます昨日から8月へのちょうど8月1日8月に
入ってから僕実はこの家
あの一人で住んでません一人でありますんでないです
8実はですねー
去年かな去年からん
去年の夏から1年間くらい実はの内緒で
ん
ずっと付き合っている彼女がいませんかー色々入って冗談はこれくらいにしましてマン
でも舌はタイトルにあるとおりでございますじゃあ私はず3節は8月からある人とこの
家で共同生活をすることが決まりましたあれ誰かっていうとして今かな
呼ぶか読んだ方が早いなんです選んでいきますが大
ね
ああああああ
殺すん
ええええええ
re
バレたか話しませんめっちゃいいんだよああああっ
のセクションか8月から私の家に住むことになりました
大臣へどうぞ
いいえ
ええええええ
というわけでちょっと1か月間弟もスバル私の順に進みます
いやマジでありがたい本当にそれはそれで俺も助かるんだけどね動画にいつもいます
みたいなわけじゃなくてただ臍に住んでるだけっていう感じなので特に深い意味はあり
ません
帰っていいか分からずはい時です静岡の方が弟がしばらくこの家にずっと言いますなぜ
僕の家に住むカって言うなんですけども実は会津9月から留学に行くことが決まりまし
て今大学の奴入ってるんですけど
大学でもなって休みバエのテストが終わって大学によっ
大学のすぐらしい弦部屋を引き払ってお金がもったいないから聞き払って
僕うちにも来ているとなぜでその留学に行くまでの8月の間は1ヶ月間だけなんです
けど僕の一杯ッ月と
いますこれによってこの外れ社長の何が変わるかと言いますとあの実はかなり+かで
ますあのですねまぁ生姜水というかこう時間が生じない場面が多かったここまで大学
卒業してこの夏まで
の4567月からこの4ヶ月からなかなかこうね常に何かしなきゃいけないっていう
状態が続いててご存知の通り東京に行くこともめちゃくちゃ増えましてお経にもいいよ
を構えることによってこの静岡の部屋と東京の部屋の両方を管理しなきゃいけないは
掃除も含めてね想像もあるして選択もあるしてねその他ボロボロの管理とかも色々あっ
て
ぶっち
でもねちょっとね一人だと無理だと思った土地があったんですよ結構ねってか無理そこ
が手伝ってくれる奴が一人家に行って掃除とかね選択後実際は編集とかもちょっと
手伝ってもらおうと思ってたりしてていろいろな場面でか
形のサポートを受けさせてもらうことができそうなのであのー僕的にはすごい
ありがたいお話でございます5が何とかしようと思ってたずっとずっと思ってたんです
けど馬場としてタイミングがなくて rain チャンネルも手を抜きたくないしてか
といって東京に行かないわけにはいかないんで無理するしかなかったんですけども
なんかこの8月からはネットがず少し僕のに
が軽くなりそうな気がしておりますこれによってちょっとメインチャンネルもっと公募
何かやりたいことができればいいなと思ってるんですけどもひとまずん
本当に大事なを育てというかぼくんちには話せ弟がいるっていう話になりますが助かり
は実態がそういうの雅紀がいるからいいじゃんと思うかもしれないんですけどあいつの
一応学生なんで勉強するのが基本なんだよな毎日道
は手伝ったり洗濯とか掃除やらせるわけにもいかないんだよねほんと部屋が汚いとよく
みんなに言われるんですけど掃除する暇もなく東京に行くこととかが結構あって本当に
時間がなかったこちらも実は夜中ずっと部屋が想像してて大部屋はきれいになったので
という意味でお前ら8月は盛り上がる月になりそうだなきゃ夏本番でてかこれからも
弾み冊をよろしくお願いします
なんかちょっといたずらしてよ
接着ちょっと来なぜ正祐運送いくれって扱い
うっはっはー
プっています
ん
持っています